when is it the appropriate time to send
those you know racy pictures The Thirst
straps
I wouldn't send anything to anyone ever
that you wouldn't that you wouldn't be
happy to see online someday I don't
think especially if someone's living in
the same town as you you don't need to
send a sexy picture to keep their
attention if you think you do then
you've got to explore why that is
have you distanced and you're not going
to see them for a while and they're in
your life really in your life then send
them a sexy picture I'm not talking
about a naked picture because I
suggested
you don't know what life brings and
never never ever to send a naked picture
you know
send a picture that looks like a
passport picture
I didn't think you were going to go to
The Other Extreme